pour la première fois l'agglomération
versailles grand parc à fait originale
pour le traditionnel ramassage des vieux
sapins de noël
c'est une collecte hippomobile qui a été
mise en place
autrement dit deux chevaux de trait une
calèche et des rippeurs les chevaux
c'est quand même agréable c'est
pédagogique c'est pas le même bruit
effectivement qu'un camion les enfants
les mêmes les gens on voit déjà qu'il
sourit en voyant les chevaux donc
effectivement c'est pas c'est pas la
même approche
et puis puis ça change c'est agréable du
8 au 13 janvier les sapins sont donc
ramassé dans trois communes noisy-le-roi
bailly et rémoulins la tâche a été
confiée à l'entreprise les calèches de
versailles dont l'écurie est composé
d'une vingtaine de chevaux de trait le
fait de les utiliser dans ce cadre là à
réel intérêt puisqu'on n'est pas moins
rapide qu'un camion en faisant du porte
à porte sur ce type de collecte donc une
efficacité quasi totale par rapport avec
une motorisés et bien sûr a un impact
écologique qui est qui et bien sûr
palpable puisque voilà cent on utilise
une énergie propre énergie renouvelable
qui est l'énergie cheval en plus du
ramassage écologique le compostage est
aussi effectué localement à la
plateforme bio yvelines située à bailly
à noisy le roi
les habitants sont ravis c'est la
première année et j'espère que ça va
continuer on n'a pas du tout l'habitude
de voir des chevaux dans nos rues donc
je suis passé voir j'avais l'information
parce que il y avait eu des flyers dans
les boîtes aux lettres
donc voilà je trouve l'initiative très
sympa l'agglomération versailles grand
parc n'exclut pas de reconduire
l'opération l'année prochaine voire même
de l'étendre à d'autres communes si
elles en font la demande